ich bin soweit
das ist kein Film über den angeblich
dunklen Osten
[Musik]
keiner über Arbeitslosigkeit und
abgehängt sein
es geht um Menschen mit Visionen
nein träume ich bin definitiv ein
Träumer
sie bleiben da und schenke uns jetzt die
Kraft für diese Beerdigung und schauen
selbstbewusst nach vorn das hier etwas
Neues entsteht da bin ich mir ganz
sicher das müssen andere Leute
entscheiden ob ich dir erinnern musste
des Ostens bin aber fakt ist wir wollen
alle gemeinsam was bewegen wegziehen
kommt nicht in Frage es wird nicht
[Musik]
jung und selbstbewusst im Osten für
viele inzwischen selbstverständlich
[Musik]
Chemnitz Anfang Juni
guten Morgen
Julia Vogt ist in ihrem Element na ich
bin schon auf Arbeit nur sichi die
25-Jährige leitet das Kultur- und
Veranstaltungshaus Weltecho an diesem
Tag geht es um ganz große Pläne
und dann würde ich sagen gehen wir den
ganzen Spaß mal an julia und ihre
Mitstreiter organisieren ein Festival
namens Cosmos einen Tag lang
aktionstände in der Innenstadt mehrere
Bühnen Stars wie der Rapper materia bis
zu 50.000 Gäste ein richtig großes Ding
vielleicht sogar größenwahnsinnig für
Chemnitz du nützt nicht den Zug aus
Leipzig dieser ist und es gibt einfach
auch nichts mehr es gibt ja keine
airbnbs mehr in dieser Stadt kein Hotel
die Zeit ist knapp viele Details noch
offen was erlaubt das Ordnungsamt was
nicht vor allem aber wie erreicht man
möglichst viele Leute vom studi bis zum
alten Karl-Marx-Städter
das ist genau ja auch die Motivation zu
sagen ihr seid alle herzlich willkommen
und wir probieren für jeden was zu
schaffen und für dich ist vielleicht der
Main Act nichts aber vielleicht freust
du dich dabei zu sein wenn die längste
Bratwurst der Welt gerade hier gebraten
wird und ins Guinness Buch darin Corte
reinkommt
Julia Vogt geboren
1996 in Chemnitz ihre Eltern sind zur
Wendezeit selbst noch Teenies heute
arbeiten sie als Lehrerin und
Finanzbeamter viele junge Menschen sind
nach der Wende weggegangen wie überall
im Osten Julias Familie blieb in dieser
Stadt der Widersprüche mit dem
zweifelhaften Ruf
[Musik]
Freiheit geworden wieder daran auf und
davon nicht noch eine Saison auf und
davon nicht noch eine Saison
Cover Beton
Bilder verschwommen geht nicht mehr um
auf und davon nicht noch eines Saison
auf und davon nicht noch eine Saison
zuletzt macht Chemnitz 2018 Schlagzeilen
damals wird ein junger Mann erstochen
die Täter sind Asylbewerber es folgen
Aufmärsche aufgebrachte Bürger müssen
sich mit gewaltbereiten rechtsextremen
die Stadtgesellschaft zeigt sich tief
gespalten
[Applaus]
für Julia nichts Neues Konfrontation mit
Neonazis kennt sie schon länger sie
führt uns an den Platz der ihr Leben
prägte mit 15 demonstrierte sie hier
gegen ein rechtsextremen Aufmarsch und
wäre fast verprügelt worden ich bin nur
so an Kindergarten vorbei gerannt und
der Fahrschule hinter mir her und du
hast Angst und du merkst wie ernst das
alles ist und die lebensbedrohlich das
auch alles ist und dann dieser Punkt von
will ich mich dem aussetzen
oder
gehe ich weg weggehen wie so viele
andere zuvor schließlich trifft Julia
eine Entscheidung jetzt erst recht sie
wird Chemnitz nicht im Stich lassen
sondern den Rechtsextremen Strukturen
etwas entgegensetzen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ungebremste Lust aufs machen alles für
das Festival
was macht denn du am 17.06 hast du Lust
zufällig noch so ein kleines Panel zu
moderieren
es gibt natürlich kein Geld ich krieg
hier gerade einen Anruf rein ich da
würde ich mal rangehen wenn es erstmal
für dich passt ich wollte eigentlich nur
wissen ob du das noch mit mit materia
auf dem Schirm hast
ich habe so ein Telefonat noch am Ohr im
Bein so ganz im Kleinen heiligen Dinge
immer
Chemnitz eine Stadt der Freiräume
das gibt halt nicht eigentlich alles
schon mal wie in Leipzig oder in Berlin
sondern du hast ganz viel Platz noch
neue Ideen zu bringen zu entwickeln und
genau das ist glaube ich so das
reizvolle dann doch an der Stadt das
zwischen all dem grauen grau du halt mit
einem kleinen Spritzer Farbe schon
extrem viel Aufmerksamkeit bekommst wer
in den Freiraum geht verzichtet bewusst
auf Sicherheit julia ist dazu bereit nur
noch zehn Tage bis zu ihrem großen Event
auch ein Festival kann schief gehen es
gibt so viele Möglichkeiten es kann
niemand kommen das Wetter kann blöd sein
es können
Nazis die Veranstaltung stürmen es
können Menschen randalieren das kann
sich Leute aufregen also was ich habe
auch irgendwie keinen Bock mich so in
die Angst treiben zu lassen sondern
finde immer wir können irgendwie
optimistisch bleiben und
das machen worauf wir Bock haben und das
machen wir seit Jahren und davon bringt
uns auch keine ab
Skatstadt Altenburg im Osten Thüringens
auch André neumann hat was Großes vor
noch stehen viele Häuser leer der
Oberbürgermeister will ihnen neues Leben
geben auch diesem alten Schulgebäude
und auch das ein ganz toller Raum
geschichtsträchtiger Raum und den werden
wir
mit einbinden in
einer Hochzeit oder eine Immatrikulation
oder jemand sagt ich habe sechs Schach
Profis dafür die hätte man ja Platz und
man will ein würdiges Schachturnier
machen alles was man sich so denken kann
soll dieser Raum auch das Gebäudes dann
Dritten zur Verfügung stehen
ein Veranstaltungshaus inklusive Spiele
Museum interaktiv und hochmodern seine
Vision eine Spiele Erlebniswelt pro Jahr
sollen hunderttausend Touristen kommen
nach Altenburg mit jetzt 30.000
Einwohnern sind sie ein Träumer ich bin
ein Träumer ich bin definitiv ein
Träumer was ich aber jeden Wünsche der
über diese Erde wandelt dass er ein
Stück weit sich das Träumen bewahrt und
wir werden hier träumen aber erfolgreich
Träumen
André Neumann geboren 1977 in Altenburg
zum Studieren und für Jobs und
Unternehmen war er auch mal fort seit
gut vier Jahren regiert er seiner
Heimatstadt der CDU-Mann ist gern
ostdeutsch und dabei fast immer
optimistisch in einer Stadt typisch für
die Entwicklungen nach der Einheit
Chemie Uranbergbau und Kohle fast alles
verschwunden das Rückgrat der Region
weggebrochen viele Menschen suchten
anders vor ihr Glück von dort wo die
Platten leerstehen strömten mal Tausende
in die Schichtarbeit die damals blieben
sind nun Rentner der Oberbürgermeister
könnte ihr Sohn sein altersmäßig Kinder
oder Enkel hier so einen Enkel bei ihnen
ich habe einen Sohn da wo in Köln seit
einiger Zeit ist die Stimmung auch in
Altenburg gereizter geflüchtete
corona-ukraine eine Krise jagt die
nächste als hätten sie nicht schon genug
durchlebt Neumann hört sich jede Meinung
an aber nicht ohne Widerspruch
den Eindruck wenn man irgendwas falsch
ist oder man klappt was richtig zusammen
ist passt aber nicht in die Zeit da wird
man teilweise abgestempelt als zwei
rechts oder irgendwas oder links oder
sonst was das also eine freie Stimme ist
nicht mehr meiner uns noch nicht mehr so
so Stimme gibt es nur unter Kumpels ja
also ich suche jetzt warum also sie
könnten in unserer Stadt alles sagen
außer es ist verfassungsfeindlichen sie
zeigt jemand an aber ihre Meinung es
kommt jetzt kein André Neumann kein
Ordnungskräfte liefen gerade rum und
haben die Parka untersucht da kommt
keiner zu Ihnen und sagt sie dürfen die
Meinung nicht haben
schönen Tag danke fürs Gespräch auch für
die Offenheit der Glaube an die
Demokratie hatte im Osten wenig Zeit zu
wachsen während der Pandemie wucherte
bei vielen Misstrauen etwa durch das
Verbot von Demonstrationen mit mehr als
35 Menschen man muss den Leuten erlauben
ihre Meinung dazu auszudrücken und das
geht nicht auf dem Sofa das geht auf so
einen großen Marktplatz wie wir ihn
haben viel besser und diese Beschränkung
auf 35 die ist der 36 der kommt wird
weggeschickt und der kann seine Meinung
nicht sagen das war ein Fehler wir sind
in der Phase wo Ideen tatsächlich noch
auch Sinn haben zu besprechen weil wir
sie mitnehmen wollen nicht Montagabend
Bürgergespräch im Rathaus Neumann stellt
seine der Spielewelt vor konstruktive
Arbeit kleinteilig mühsam
vor dem Rathaus sammelt sich zur
gleichen Zeit die Wut wie in vielen
Städten montagabends gut 300
Demonstranten auch Rechtsextreme sind
darunter
[Musik]
[Applaus]
genau
da draußen geht es gegen die
corona-maßnahmen aber auch gegen
steigende Preise
manche solidarisieren sich mit Russland
[Applaus]
viele Demonstranten behaupten
Deutschland sei keine Demokratie mehr
Umfragen machen eine unsichtbare Grenze
sichtbar seit Jahrzehnten viele Menschen
im Osten Fremde mit der Demokratie sowie
sie aus dem Westen kam mit dem
momentanen Funktionieren unserer
Staatsform zufrieden sind im Westen dem
nach 66 Prozent im Osten nur 45
woher kommt das
damit beschäftigt sich einer an fast
höchster Stelle im Kanzleramt sitzt der
ostbeauftragte der Regierung Carsten
Schneider 13 Jahre vor der Wende in
Erfurt geboren er meint
die Erfahrungen mit der Staatspartei SED
und mit einer friedlichen Revolution
wirken bis heute nach
westdeutsche engagieren sich in Parteien
vielen im Osten liegen das fern in time
wird eben Demokratie auch anders geprägt
Direktor
und dann platzt es eher mal raus und
dann ist sehr schnell bei
Demonstrationen auf der Straße als
erfahrenes
elementpolitischer Gestaltung nämlich
mit der Demonstration auf der Straße ein
ganzes System zum Einsturz zu bringen
und deswegen ist das für viele Menschen
im Osten einen Teil der politischen
Beteiligung und Ausdrucksweise das
anders als im Westen ist eben anders und
damit der Andersartigkeit muss man eben
umgehen können
hier ist jetzt in the Mitteldorf nicht
ja in einem wunderschönen Altmark
Sachsen-Anhalt
im blaulichtmuseum ist die DDR nicht tot
zu kriegen weil die dorfjungs ihre
Relikte lieben
[Applaus]
50 dahinten
8000 Liter Brunnenwasser für den Pool
sollen quer über den Hof mit der Tatra
Feuerwehr
der Traktor K700 stammt ursprünglich aus
der Sowjetunion
unbedingt immer haben fehlt noch ein
Fuhrpark dann haben wir gute
Tauschgeschäft gemacht mit anderen
teilen und dann haben wir den hier in
der Werkstatt reingenommen haben den
komplett zerlegt den Motor komplett neu
zusammengebaut mit neuen Teilen Kolben
neue Buchsen neu und wieder aufgebaut
selber machen improvisieren
als Ossis führen Sie sich klar im
Vorteil gerade jetzt
jeder hat mit jedem gehandelt jeder
musste Vitamin B haben Beziehungen ich
musste mit dem gut können mit dem und
wenn ich das mache dann kriege ich das
und das hat sich doch denke ich schon
über die Generation nach uns und auch
die noch da drauf doch noch übertragen
weil die Eltern das ja noch so
weiterleben und das ist in der jetzigen
Zeit wieder mehr gefragt denn je und
jetzt kommt das wieder hoch und da sind
die Ossis gut aufgestellt schon früher
dürft schon reichen aber wenn wir jetzt
immer füllen dann holen wir komplett das
Museum wird von einem Verein betrieben
die Jungs machen ehrenamtlich mit
es ist aber auch ein Abenteuerspielplatz
für die ganze Clique
wegziehen vielleicht sogar den Westen
unvorstellbar
und genug los ist auch immer ja und wenn
eure Jungs mal gehen würden
meiner geht nicht meiner würde nicht
gehen
der ist ja aufgewachsen ist seine Heimat
der wir hier nicht weg das hat der von
Anfang an gesagt er möchte hier bleiben
florian ist glasfasermonteur geboren
zehn Jahre nach dem Mauerfall
Max Jahrgang 2001 lernt
IT-Systemelektroniker Christian Jahrgang
91 studiert Katastrophenschutz
drei für die der Westen weder glänzt
noch lockt
[Musik]
ihr Museumsladen ist deutlich besser
gefüllt als ein echter in der DDR
jetzt sind wir am Konsum gelandet
wir gucken mal was es so schönes gibt
normalerweise kommt das beste immer zum
Schluss aber damit haben wir jetzt schon
angefangen hier ja
[Musik]
bei Oma und Opa noch zu Hause immer so
rum lag ja von früher erzählen seine
Eltern und Großeltern eher gutes viel
nachgefragt habe er bisher nicht
[Musik]
ich bin halt doch technikbegeistert
einfach quasi der und um den Rest habe
ich noch gar nicht so den Kopf gemacht
ja und wenn du dich versuchst
einzudenken in so einem Land wo man
nicht wegkommt also ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen
mich stört es nicht wenn ich nicht
wegfahre ich mache meinen Urlaub auf
Oldtimertreffen oder ja Verhalten zur
Ostsee aber ich mag meinen Kirchturm in
der Nähe also ich finde das schon ich
muss nicht irgendwo weit wegfahren oder
mich stört das nicht
[Musik]
ihr neues das Spielzeug
eine nva-panzerfähre
[Musik]
die Kriegstechnik wollen sie nicht
verherrlichen das Ungetüm habe schon
Kühe aus dem Elbhochwasser gerettet sie
können damit heute zum Spaß rumfahren
der trotzige Stolz aus ostdeutsche er
ist auch eine Reaktion
[Musik]
auf die Erfahrung in manchem weniger
wert zu sein
eine Gleichsetzung vom Lohn wäre schon
cool ja sage ich mal so gleich gleiche
Tarife für Ost und West
das macht ja
eigentlich Sinn ich bin in dem Fall
glasfasermonteur und fahre auch mal ein
paar kupferstörungen Messen in
Niedersachsen von meiner Firma die ist
Autofahren 10 Minuten weg und ja da gibt
es halt bisschen mehr Geld als
für den Osten
[Musik]
zur nächsten Autobahn ist es von hier so
weit wie in kaum einer anderen Ecke der
Republik das nervt aber sonst viele es
an nichts
[Musik]
Heimat ist natürlich das da wo man groß
geworden ist wenn man wer ich jetzt ein
im Westen geboren werdet der Westen
Hochheimer und generell ich habe auch
nur hier gewohnt und wohne auch nur hier
ich bleibe hier also ich liebe meine
Heimat gerade den Zusammenhalt der ist
hier verdammt groß du kannst nachts
überall hingehen oder so und klopfen
dann hilft dir jemand im Westen würde
ich vermuten dass es vielleicht nicht
immer so ist dass jemand anhält wenn du
eine Panne hast oder das ist vielleicht
schon eine andere Mentalität würde ich
würde ich mal so behaupten oh
plötzlich kommt es tatsächlich drauf an
ein Wagenheber wäre jetzt sehr hilfreich
Werkzeugkiste
Christian ist los Hilfe holen wird schon
klappen irgendwie
Schnaps Mirabelle
sei du jetzt bei uns schenke uns Kraft
bei der aller Aufregung und segne uns
und diesen Gottesdienst Amen
Schleife ganz im Osten des Ostens
Tagebaugebiet laut Sprichwort erschuf
Gott die Lausitz und der Teufel dann die
Kohle
[Musik]
Pfarrerin Jadwiga Marling glaubt dass
das Gute siegen wird
[Musik]
schuleinführungsgottesdienst die
Erstklässler auf die weite Welt
vorbereiten gleichzeitig die alten
mitnehmen die von Umbrüchen geprägten
von Wendezeit und Kohle aus
Gott wir bitten dich für alle
Jugendlichen die jetzt ihre Ausbildung
angefangen haben oder zum Studium gehen
gibt dass sie gut zurechtkommen und neue
Freundschaften schließen und so geht nun
in diesen Tag und in diese Woche mit dem
Segen Gottes
ja wieder maling
1983 geboren ihre Familie gehört zu den
sorgen einer Minderheit mit slawischer
Sprache und Kultur ihr Vater auch
erbpfarrer setzt sich während der Wende
für deren Rechte ein
sie selbst reist viel durch die Welt und
landet erst einmal im Westen
ich habe ja längere Zeit in Tübingen und
in Heidelberg auch studiert
es war wunderschön und es war Wahnsinn
welche Mittel die dort hatten welche
Bibliotheken welche
Professoren wie reicht die Gegend war
wie das schon auch der Umweltgedanke
viel stärker in Baden-Württemberg gelebt
wurde
und doch war es für mich eine zu satte
Landschaft zu satte Landschaft zu satte
Gesellschaft ich brauche glaube ich ein
Stück weit die Peripherie das
zerbrochene dort wo man was aufbauen
kann und deshalb bin ich gerne hier in
der Lausitz
Wunden heilen neues Selbstbewusstsein
wecken dazu gehört für Marlin auch die
sorbische Kultur und Sprache
Mensch
auf Wiedersehen
ihr Pfarrhaus steht für vieles offen
heute hat sie Musikanten aus Berlin und
Cottbus zu Gast Anti
braunkohleaktivisten sie wollen unter
anderem im Wald am Tagebau spielen
übernachten dürfen sie bei ihr
aber ich freue mich wird voll gut heute
Turnier Auftakt ja aufgeregt naja
Schlafmöglichkeiten oben
ansonsten zwei Supermärkte ein Döner in
Schleife eine Pizzeria nebenan
in die Lausitz kam zu DDR-Zeiten 10.000
Arbeiter malochen in der Kohle das war
der lebensstolz für viele etwas aufbauen
für die Kinder und die Enkel doch viele
von denen sind inzwischen weggezogen das
Ergebnis ist auf Tiefe Entfremdung
das heißt die Eltern bleiben auch ein
Stück weit in ihren Gedanken und in
ihrem auch in dieser Trauer über
vielleicht auch die DDR-Zeit was sie
alles verloren haben
und ihre Kinder und Enkel lieben in
einer neuen anderen Welt und es ist
nicht untypisch dass die Leute hier dann
vielleicht ihre Eltern Großeltern
vielleicht eher AFD und rechtes Spektrum
wählen und die Kinder und Enkel
vielleicht bei Fridays for future
mitmachen
entwurzelte Menschen ständige
Transformation Dörfer werden zur Wüste
wegen der Kohle darunter
vor kurzem standen hier noch Häuser und
Gärten und das Dorf auf dem abrissplan
ob die Bagger tatsächlich kommen weil es
niemand
dass diese Ortslage mürose jemals
ausgekohlt wird das glaube ich denken
nur noch die wenigsten und wenn hier so
viel erstmal kaputt gemacht wurde und
zerstört wurde wird es Jahre und
Jahrzehnte dauern bis hier etwas Neues
wächst aber das hier etwas Neues
entsteht da bin ich mir ganz sicher
nebenan im teils schon gerodeten Wald
spielen die Gäste der Pfarrerin ein
kleines protestkonzert gegen die Kohle
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ein paar Kilometer weiter geht Malling
den Wandel ganz konkret an auf dem
Pfarrhaus entsteht eine Solaranlage
na alles soweit geklappt heute
und morgen geht es theoretisch dann
weiter oder
Strom aus neuer Energie neben dem
Sterbenden Tagebau es ist auch Symbol
für eine neue Erzählung über
Ostdeutschland
sagt einer der den Osten selbstbewusster
machen will
was war einbringen können in diese
Gesellschaft ist einfach eine unfassbare
Fähigkeit aus nichts etwas zu machen und
Herausforderungen zu groß wie auch sind
irgendwie annehmen zu müssen und auch
aus und sich nicht umwerfen zu lassen
weil die 16 Millionen Menschen die haben
ganze System mit umgeworfen und sind
auch nicht mit dem goldenen Löffel
geboren sondern haben sich das meist die
mal allermeisten hat erarbeitet
und das und das ist schon etwas worauf
man sehr stolz sein kann und dann geht
man auch mit Krisen im Zweifel anders um
also nimmt die einfach an das
doch was macht manche zu machen und
andere nicht
Spurensuche in Wittenberg in
Sachsen-Anhalt
also ich glaube das ist letztendlich so
das Lebensmittel von jenen
selbstständigen alles Gute der Welt
geschieht nur weil jemand mehr tut als
er tun muss
simon schandert hatte ein Unternehmen
mitgegründet dass Batteriespeicher für
Gewerbekunden herstellt sie haben
Abnehmer in 80 Ländern und es werden
immer mehr die Technologie ist völlig
neu simon hat sie selbst erfunden sie
macht die Speicher besonders effizient
ja und hier sehen wir im Prinzip ein
Batteriespeicher mit in Summe 100
Kilowattstunden was so in etwa dem also
10 Tage eines Einfamilienhauses
entsprechen würde das bedeutet wenn ich
so ein Speichern Keller habe könnten wir
uns sehen Tage völlig autark von den
Energiespeichern die Batteriespeicher
hier versorgen
[Musik]
das ist ein wendekind geboren 1989 sein
Vater arbeitet zu DDR-Zeiten als
Elektriker macht sich nach der Wende
selbstständig Simon geht zum Studieren
nach Berlin hat dort mit einem Kumpel
die Idee zur Firma gründen wollen sie
aber nirgendwo anders als in der Heimat
Wittenberg und zwar eigentlich klar wir
brauchen Fläche wir brauchen Platz wenn
unsere Idee tatsächlich aufgeht und
Fläche und Platz ist in Berlin nicht
vorhanden und man muss auch ganz ehrlich
sagen Wittenberg hat eine sehr sehr gut
und ausgeprägte Kultur aber auch das
Thema Gastronomie beispielsweise ja man
muss sich auch immer wohl fühlen man
muss darf auch mal ausgehen können ja
man hat einen sehr sehr familiäres
Umfeld und genau das macht er halt auch
Wittenberg aus und deswegen fühlen wir
uns hier sowohl
wie wurde Simon wir ist Besuch in Zahna
einem Örtchen nahe Wittenberg hier wurde
er geboren seine Eltern lieben und
arbeiten noch immer hier
[Musik]
hallo ja schön euch zu sehen
die Wende sahen sie nicht als Einbruch
sondern als Chance die berufliche
Selbstständigkeit war ein Risiko sagt
simonsvater aber es habe sich gelohnt
auch Simons Mutter arbeitete immer wie
die meisten Frauen im Osten
überbehütet war er nicht
diese Arbeit die ich dann hatte ja hat
das hat die Kinder auch geprägt weil man
immer berufstätig war sie waren
selbständig mussten oft alleine bleiben
aber Simon wollte das auch der war
pflichtbewusst er war ehrgeizig ja sein
Ehrgeiz hatten vielleicht auch durch uns
ein bisschen angetrieben
vom Vater hat Simon nicht nur das
Verständnis für Technik auch die Neugier
auf die Welt nicht nur schmoren im
eigenen Saft
wir haben uns ja Motorrad angeschafft
wir sind eine kleine Motorradgruppe und
da suchen wir immer Ziele in in
Westdeutschland aus
wir waren eine Schwarzwald gewesen wir
waren in Bayern gewesen im im sauer im
Sauerland in der Zoomen immer so schöne
Städte aus und und gucken uns die
schönen Städte an wie sah früher ging
das früher durften wir das nicht wichtig
ist eben der Kontakt zwischen dem
Menschen
einmal im Monat wird gegrillt in Simons
Firma das Team ist gemischt einige aus
dem Westen anderer aus dem Osten
mittlerweile arbeiten 180 Menschen hier
und es werden immer mehr
eine Erweiterung ist schon geplant
[Musik]
wir wollen hier in Wittenberg wachsen
wir sehen hier knapp 10.000 Quadratmeter
noch freies Grundstück noch ist Bauland
erschwinglich hier im Osten ein großer
Vorteil für Mauerblümchen Bescheidenheit
sieht Simon schandert keinen Grund
naja also ich vergleiche mich ungerne
mit mit solchen Persönlichkeiten ja ich
bin da tatsächlich dann eher da daran
die die Lösung tatsächlich auch zu
entwickeln ja das müssen andere Leute
entscheiden ob ich dir erinnern musste
das Ostens bin aber fakt ist wir wollen
alle gemeinsam was bewegen und da müssen
wir einfach gemeinsam daran arbeiten
in Chemnitz ist es soweit
hallo hallo hallo
[Musik]
auf die eins bin ich das kosmosfestival
beginnt
hallo
ein großer Tag für Organisatoren Julia
Vogt aber er beginnt nicht gut
denkst du dann dran die Helfer zu
unterweisen über die Absage von materia
wenn das veröffentlicht wurde
ein Star hat abgesagt am Abend vorher
der Rapper materia wegen Krankheit und
er ist nicht der einzige
es gab Dreiecks die leider absagen
mussten ja und dementsprechend haben wir
uns gestern da glaube ich ein bisschen
deprimieren lassen davon aber heute sind
wir voller Elan und haben Bock let's go
ist das Wild alles nein sie als
Festivalleiterin ist Julia
verantwortlich für alles für Sicherheit
und gute Laune
wir haben eine Anweisung bekommen wir
müssen auf der linken Seite Backstage in
Deutschland schaffen ich gehe jetzt mal
dort hinten diesen Chaos beseitigen
Ernst wir sind Kabelbinder und es ist
verschraubt herrlich
herrlich
Sascha mein Sonnenschein hier sagt mal
hast du noch irgendjemand der mir ein
Bauzaun entfernen kann
schöner scheiß der Zaun kommt weg gerade
noch rechtzeitig für das Ordnungsamt
die festivalorganisatoren sind auffällig
jung nach der Wende ist nahezu eine
ganze Generation abgewandert ein
organischer Übergang von erfahrenen zu
jungen fand nicht statt
okay reicht mir
das fehlt diese Führungsposition die
danach gekommen ist so dass ich dann mit
Mitte 30 vielleicht den Führungsposition
einnehmen sondern es gab nur die Option
macht das jetzt mit 20 oder lass es
das Festival beginnt die sonst leeren
Plätze füllen sich
Ziel der Organisatoren neue gemeinsame
Erlebnisse schaffen für möglichst viele
eine Stadtgesellschaft bilden und
Vorurteile abbauen das geht nicht ohne
Konfrontation
[Musik]
das ist ein Problem
und da die Ausländer die flaschenakte
Dings hauen das kann ich mir ja gar
nicht vorstellen woher wissen Sie denn
dass das Ausländer sind
sieht man den doch nicht an auch
deutsche haben eine andere Hautfarbe
lassen Sie sich inspirieren
also das finde ich immer so krass diese
Stigmatisierung habe ich gesehen dass
das ein Ausländer ist es gibt ja nicht
also
wütend bin ich da ich probiere mich
heute nicht aber eine runterziehen zu
lassen bis morgen an mich Ranzen sondern
halt erst mal ein bisschen
weiterzumachen und ja eigentlich ist es
vielleicht gut dass genau diese Menschen
über unsere Festivalgelände gehen und
anderen Menschen begegnen die das halt
nicht so sehen und die da vielleicht
auch was sagen
Chemnitz und Julia Vogt zwei auf der
Suche nach Identität wie gesamtdeutsch
wie weltoffen will man sein und wie sehr
aufs ostdeutsch sein beharren es ist ein
Balanceakt
[Musik]
manche von Julias älteren Freunden haben
die Fragen für sich beantwortet die
identifizieren sich noch krass als
Ostdeutsche also das was ich die
Argumentation für mich ist auch
schlüssig und ich kann das
rationalisiert nachempfinden aber ich
führe das nicht tatsächlich also ich
habe nicht die Empfindung dass ich sage
ich identifiziere mich als Ostdeutsche
die ist nicht in mir drin und das ist
irgendwie dann schon auch wieder
aufregend was dann doch diese ja diese
paar Jahre unterschied machen
in Sachen Identität verläuft durch
Deutschland eine Grenze fragt man im
Westen dann fühlen sich nur elf Prozent
in erster Linie westdeutsch 84 Prozent
definieren sich gesamtdeutsch anders im
Osten hier begreifen sich 30 Prozent
ausdrücklich als ostdeutsch nur zwei
Drittel als gesamtbundesbürger
mehr als 30 Jahre nach der Vereinigung
der ostbeauftragte findet das gar nicht
so schlecht er sieht im ostdeutsch sein
etwas zupackendes optimistisches
[Musik]
hat Selbstbewusstsein und mit beiden
Beinen wie in der Gesellschaft stehen
auf was mit Identität und Anerkennung zu
tun und
es trifft dich nur auf Ostdeutschland
sondern auch auf ganz Osteuropa sich
anpassen musste an das westliche ist und
jede Abweichung von der Norm als eine
negative Abweichung gesehen wird
was ich für falsch halte und aus diesem
Grunde jetzt mehr drum dieses in den
letzten 20 30 Jahren stärker gewordene
Bewusstsein aus Deutschland das gab es
vor der Wende aus meiner Sicht nicht es
hat sich herausgeprägt das positiv
umzumünzen
im thüringischen Altenburg hallo der
Oberbürgermeister ist da besucht andre
Neumann die älteste Bürgerin der Stadt
alles Gute alles alles Gute wünsche ich
Ihnen jedes Jahr wieder aufs Neue ja
107 Jahre alt wird Gerda Metze da
gratuliert Neumann natürlich gern
der Altersdurchschnitt Altenburgs 57
Jahre Tendenz steigend solche Termine
nehmen also zu Schnittchen Kuchen süße
Pflicht
115 müssen wir schaffen er möchte dass
du 115 wirst damit er jedes Jahr hierher
kommen kann dass ich
[Gelächter]
Altenburgs Einwohnerzahl hat sich seit
der Wende halbiert Neumann will diesen
Trend umkehren
wir schrumpfen weiterhin und müssen in
diesem Schrumpfprozess aber attraktiv
für Tourist für Menschen die hier leben
wollen für Unternehmer für Mitarbeiter
irgendwie es schaffen so attraktiv zu
sein dass wir die Kurve bekommen und die
Dinge wieder füllen wir werden nie
wieder 60.000 Einwohner aber wenn es in
40 50 Jahren mal wieder 40.000 sind dann
ist hier wirklich was gelungen
noch hat der verfallvorsprung doch in
manchem Gemäuer regt sich wieder was wie
im alten Clubhaus der
Konsumgenossenschaft
spontan Besuch des Bürgermeisters das
hat doch
noch eine Chance
vorne die Bühne für ein appellnachmittag
früher wurde hier im sozialistischen
Kollektiv gefeiert jetzt sind
Kunstschaffende eingezogen fast alle
kommen aus dem Westen sie malen
bildhauern bieten Töpferkurse an
ich habe das Gefühl dass einfach sehr
viel glücklich ist also viel mehr als
jetzt im Westen in Köln in NRW wer so
ein Projekt überhaupt nicht möglich
also das ist auch übersättigt dort ja
wir Lust haben selber uns Räumen oder
selber Räume mitzugestalten
gemeinschaftlich ist das für uns
natürlich hier super schön und für uns
ist da hier der Leerstand natürlich
airpotential als eine Bedrohung
ja
erst zu entdecken zu öffnen und dann zu
entwickeln das ist so ein Stück weit der
Versuch
entwickeln Träumen mit Bebauungsplan wo
andere Neumann hin will mit seiner Stadt
zeigt der schließlich von hoch oben
genau
dort genau dort die Platten will er
weiter schrumpfen Rückbau Ost in der
historischen Mitte soll dafür umso mehr
Leben einziehen
zur Boomtown Leipzig sind es gerade mal
50 km das bringt den rathausschef ins
Scherzen also im Grunde genommen werden
wir uns so entwickeln dass irgendwann
Leipzig den Antrag stellen wird
eingemeindet werden zu können und das
wird eine kleine politische Diskussion
sein aber am Ende werden wir Leipzig
dann auch gerne allgemein und einen
weiteren Ortsteil dazu gewinnen daran
arbeite ich jeden Tag von früh bis
abends
Abend in Chemnitz auf dem
kosmos-festival ist es so voll geworden
wie gehofft auch ohne den Rapper materia
und ohne große Zwischenfälle
das sind alle
wüten und es ist großartig ich freue
mich dass es so läuft wie es läuft und
ich freue mich auf das was nach Cup
jedes Jahr will Chemnitz nun in seinen
Kosmos einladen und sich als moderne
Großstadt präsentieren weltoffen und
aufregend
[Musik]
[Applaus]
auch die altmarke wurde jetzt gern Party
machen endlich kommt der Wagenheber
[Musik]
auf dem Grundstück von Florians Opa
glühen sie schon mal vor für ihre
klubnacht im Freien mit selbstgebauter
Bühne für DJ Max und mit Dieselgenerator
für den Strom natürlich aus der DDR
sonst könnte Christian ihn ja nicht
reparieren im Notfall ich Sorge über die
richtige
die Energien fließen auf ihrem selbst
kreierten Mini-Festival
altmarke flüster
wer weiß vielleicht wird daraus ja mal
was ganz Großes man ist ja in
Ostdeutschland
einer Gegend in der die Zukunft offener
scheint als anderswo
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was ich in 10 Jahren mache
ich weiß es nicht ich weiß es wirklich
nicht aber auf jeden Fall ich bleib hier
nirgendwo anders
ich bin wie gesagt auch sehr
heimatverbunden und was ich hier aufbaue
möchte ich auch nicht noch ein zweites
Mal aufbauen und die Freunde die kann
man nicht mitnehmen die sind nun mal
hier und das ist doch das beste Geschenk
was man endlich haben kann ich träume
davon dass wir in einer Gesellschaft
leben die offen ist für neues
die Menschen von außen willkommen heißt
und mit ihnen die Zukunft und diese
Landschaft hier miteinander gestaltet in
all ihrer Schönheit und zerbrochenheit
es bedarf halt manchmal immer einem
Vorreiter der sagt ich habe eine Idee
die müssen wir doch hier umsetzen komme
ich nehme euch alle mit ja also nicht so
unmöglich in zehn Jahren wird Altenburg
die Perle Mitteldeutschland sein
zumindest weiß es dann jeder und für
mich selber ist die Stadt Altenburg für
immer mit meinem Leben verbunden dass
ich vielleicht mal punktuell woanders
bin aber ich werde nicht nur geboren
sein in dieser Stadt sondern bestimmt
auch wieder gehen in dieser Stadt ich
bin gespannt ich bin gespannt bleib
offen dafür was kommt ich werde auf
jeden Fall hier sein in dieser Stadt
also wenn ihr in zehn Jahren wiederkommt
befindet mich hier
[Musik]